this is one businessman in Germany who
wants the trade negotiations with the US
and Canada to succeed no tariffs
unlimited free trade it sky buta Meyers
dream he's the CEO of an engineering
company that employs about 1300 staff
90% of the special machines built here
are for export and we need free trade so
that we can do our work without
additional costs and bureaucracy there's
a direct connection the more free trade
and more easily we can sell our machines
and the better we'll do for Martina
colored fella that sounds too simple she
also heads an engineering company but
she's against TTIP and CETA that's why
she's meeting with members of the Green
Party today TTIP and CETA go through
that doesn't necessarily mean I'll be
able to export to Canada or the US
without any difficulties I'll still have
to follow the same certification rules
as before so we should be having this
conversation on an entirely different
level
only a few entrepreneurs have voiced
opposition to TTIP but Hamid Fela
believes the agreement includes more
provisions than necessary for free trade
including provisions regarding public
and consumer rights and environmental
standards what bothers me most is that
the agreement creates an entirely
different contractual system it's being
called a free trade agreement but I
believe that it's actually a lot more
than that it touches on all aspects of
society how we live today
kai Boone Tamiya shares her view
he says the agreements do indeed
encompass more than just free trade but
he still favors them we're not really
happy about that aspect the points of
contention in this negotiation have
nothing to do with us I don't believe
anyone anywhere in the world is opposed
to a machine companies selling their
products globally my company generally
isn't involved in the points under
dispute they're arguing about
agricultural products about services
about norms Kobus produces machines that
bind books the company has had a
subsidiary in the u.s. for years now
that's how they know just how
complicated it is to export products to
the US or import products from the u.s.
back to Germany there are different
customs rules for different products so
I have to be very careful what I call
something if one of my staff calls
something a bearing instead of a sleeve
I might find myself accidentally
violating a customs regulation that's
why in addition to a production
specialist I need to have a tax expert a
lawyer and a linguist look at my
documentation so you get an idea of the
hurdles we face and TTIP would eliminate
that that's the most important thing it
would do for us
fine good matino Hamid fella disagrees
she and her husband built up their
company which produces small scale hydro
power plants demand in North America has
risen sharply the strength of German
products on the export market is first
of all due to the innovation the
inventiveness and the strength of German
mid-sized companies they come up with
great products that are in high demand
around the world that's what's key
that's what creates demand for contracts
and what we're calling free trade it's
reservations like these that are also
slowing negotiations kybun Tamiya
doesn't believe TTIP will be signed in
the next five years